Hello and welcome to a special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈浪漫史》特别加更版节目。
We like to call these general questions.
我们喜欢把这叫作“常规问题”。
General questions?
常规问题？
Who I heard an extra voice on there.
我听到里面好像多了一个声音。
Who was that?
那是谁？
It's me.
是我。
I've decided not to leave.
我决定不走了。
If we can't get rid of it, we keep saying just click off.
如果我们赶不走他，就一直说点开。
Shut the laptop.
合上笔记本电脑。
Is this our first ever guest on the general questions?
这是我们在常规问题环节的第一位嘉宾吗？
General questions.
常规问题。
Very exciting.
太令人激动了。
Chris, thanks for being here.
克里斯，谢谢你能来。
Chris wrote game night episode 15, which we did a great discussion on that a couple of days ago.
克里斯写了第15集《游戏之夜》，几天前我们对这一集进行了精彩的讨论。
And Chris is back to answer all your questions and dispel his memories.
克里斯这次回来是为了回答大家的所有问题，并唤醒他的回忆。
He's wearing the same shirt.
他穿着同一件衬衫。
We're always the same clothes as a few days ago.
我们总是穿着几天前一样的衣服。
We've been under the redidender.
我们一直在这个红……
It's the redidender.
就是这个红……
We had so much to catch up on.
我们有太多事情要聊了。
We haven't met the computers since Monday.
我们从周一开始就没见过电脑了。
All right.
好吧。
So, Alec, what do we got?
那么，亚历克，我们有什么？
Here we go.
我们开始吧。
So one of our one of our biggest supporters, not our biggest or the show's biggest supporters Swarly memes has a lot to say and So Swarly means I'm sure you're listening to this.
我们的一位，或者说我们最大的，或者说剧集最大的粉丝之一——Swarly memes有很多话要说，所以Swarly memes，我确信你在听这个。
I hope that currently this is being clipped like right now I'm in a Swarly meme that would be incredibly exciting and Swarly meme says Chris Harris That's the mini cherry on top of the regular cherry on top of the Sunday of awesomeness that is this podcast and then And I'm just going to read this lovely note to Chris with the question at the end.
我希望现在这期节目正在被剪辑成短视频，此刻我正处于一个Swarly meme里，那将是难以置信的兴奋，Swarly memes说：“克里斯·哈里斯，这简直是这场精彩绝伦的播客圣代冰淇淋上锦上添花的那个樱桃，再加一层又加一层的樱桃。”然后，我只想给克里斯读一下这条可爱的留言，最后还有一个问题。
Chris, what I love about your episodes is how we always find ourselves in silly situations like game night, club night, award night, concert night, removing tattoo, fixing a car, hippie wedding venue, effed up, house or subway, but they still have so much heart and force the characters to reveal their true selves or grow into a better person.
克里斯，我最喜欢你的剧集的地方在于，我们总会发现自己陷入一些疯狂的情境中，比如游戏之夜、俱乐部之夜、颁奖之夜、演唱会之夜、洗纹身、修车、嬉皮士婚礼场地、糟糕的房子或地铁，但这些剧集仍然充满了温情，迫使角色展现出真实的自我，或者成长为更好的人。
Because in the end, it's not those silly moments with the people we love dearly that we remember, not the big weddings and whatnot.
因为到头来，我们记住的并不是和我们深爱的人在一起时那些疯狂的时刻，不是盛大的婚礼之类的事情。
So to turn that into a bit of a question, Chris, can you just because you do these larger episodes often going all the way up to subway wars and that size, can you start putting together the scope versus the character?
所以把这个转化为一个问题，克里斯，你能不能——因为你经常创作这些宏大的剧集，一直到《地铁大战》这种规模的——你能谈谈场面规模与人物塑造的关系吗？
Yeah, I'm torn between such a lovely compliment and also like being exposed for having a very simple formula for everything I've ever written.
是的，我一方面觉得这是个非常可爱的赞美，另一方面又觉得自己被曝光了，原来我写过的所有东西都有一个非常简单的公式。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't know if I think of it as, you know, it's always, you know, how much a mother was always great about these are the big moments in this person's life.
我不知道我是否会这样想，你知道的，《老爸老妈浪漫史》一直很棒的一点就是，这些是一个人生活中的重大时刻。
And that's the virtue of the perspective of the dad talking to his kids years later is like, we have an excuse to skip over the small things and talk about like, this is when I started dating this person.
这也是父亲多年后对孩子们说话这种视角的好处，就好像我们有一个借口可以跳过琐事，直接谈论诸如“这是我开始和这个人约会的时候”、“这是这两人分手的时候”、“这是这个人回归的时候”。
This is when these two broke up.
这就是这两人分手的时候。
This is when this person returned.
这是这个人回归的时候。
And so I think the big events go along with that, and they're always, they're always fun to put people in, to put characters in a new situation, obviously, just to see how they'll react.
所以我觉得重大事件与之相辅相成，把人们、把角色置于新的情境中总是很有趣，显然，只是为了看他们会如何反应。
But no, I feel lucky that I got to write a lot of these, especially in these early seasons.
不过说真的，我觉得自己很幸运能写出这么多集，尤其是在前几季。
You know, Carter and Craig came in with the idea about the club.
你知道的，卡特和克雷格带着关于俱乐部的想法来了。
They came in with Barney and Game Night.
他们带着巴尼和游戏之夜来了。
So it was a lot of fun to play with those worlds that the characters got to jump into.
所以能玩转那些角色们纵身跃入的世界，真的非常有趣。
It's also like there are big events and how I met your mother, but you could make the argument that every episode is a big event or he wouldn't be telling the story.
这就好比《老爸老妈浪漫史》里有很多重大事件，但你也可以争辩说，每一集都是重大事件，否则他就不会讲这个故事了。
Yeah.
对。
It feels like if he's telling it, it lingered for him and it also shaped him.
感觉既然他在讲，说明这件事对他来说挥之不去，并且也塑造了他。
When we pitched the show, we pitched like it's the 100 best stories of your 20s and 30s, hoping that we'd hit 100 episodes and then we did 208.
当我们推销这部剧时，我们说这是你20多岁和30多岁时最棒的100个故事，当时希望我们能拍到100集，结果我们拍了208集。
So that back 100 Nate, we're just more like B minus, C plus.
所以后来的那100集，内特，我们更像是B减、C加水平。
But it's also like the, is it Gene Shepherd who you keep referring to the critical story?
但这也像是，是吉恩·谢泼德吗？你一直提到那个关键故事？
Yeah, Gene Shepherd.
对，吉恩·谢泼德。
Yeah.
对。
It's the pineapple incident.
这就是菠萝事件。
We talk a lot about like Ted is mythologizing his life, you know, he's like, we all do, right?
我们经常讨论泰德在将他的人生神话化，你知道的，他就像我们所有人一样，对吧？
We're all the main characters in our stories and what are the things you'll remember 25 years from 2005?
我们都是自己故事中的主角，在2005年之后的25年里，你会记住哪些事情？
And that was the test of season one of the show.
那是该剧第一季的考验。
And I think Game Night was a good one because it's so eventful.
我觉得《游戏之夜》是个很好的例子，因为它发生了太多事。
It raises the bar on how eventful and memorable you have to try to make things in the show because he has to remember it in the future.
它提高了你在剧中必须努力让事情变得多么富有事件性和难忘的标准，因为他必须在未来记住它。
And I love that notion, Josh, like Ted's mythologizing his own because I do feel like that's such a part of it is, you know, even the re-returned, like giving these names to these events.
乔希，我很喜欢这个概念，比如泰德将自己的经历神话化，因为我觉得这确实是其中的一部分，你知道的，甚至连“再次回归”也是如此，给这些事件起这样的名字。
The re-returned, yes.
再次回归，是的。
Very Jean Shepherd, making the events.
非常吉恩·谢泼德风格，让事件变成现实。
It's a historical document, right?
这是一份历史文献，对吧？
It's like the Battle of Valley Forge.
就像福吉谷战役一样。
And also the kind of coded language that friend groups develop.
还有朋友圈里形成的某种暗语。
You know, you have this kind of Patois.
你知道，你们有这种特殊的方言。
Craig, Sarah had this question a few weeks ago and it fits nicely now of like, you know, the Supreme Court, if the chief justices is in the majority, they get to choose who writes the opinion.
克雷格，莎拉几周前问过这个问题，现在把它放进来正合适：你知道的，最高法院里，如果首席大法官在多数派中，他们就可以选择谁来写意见书。
You and Carter obviously got to choose who writes each episode was Chris at a certain point chosen for a certain scope, a certain kind of episode.
你和卡特显然可以挑选谁来写每一集，克里斯在某个特定时刻是被选中去写某种特定规模、某种特定类型的剧集吗？
And in general, how did you decide how many you guys would write and how many you would give away?
总的来说，你们是怎么决定你们俩写多少集、分给别人多少集的？
Boy, I mean, in season one, I can't say there was much of a formula that was more just like keeping our head above water and stuff.
天哪，我是说，在第一季中，我不能说有什么固定的公式，那更多只是像竭尽全力维持生计之类的。
And I think, you know, Chris, I think you were three of them in season one.
而且我认为，你知道，克里斯，我觉得你在第一季里写了三集。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
I did, yeah.
我写了，是的。
And I'd say that that's because we knew Chris would kill it.
我要说的是，那是因为我们知道克里斯会大获成功。
You're excited to give a guy like Chris an episode because you know it's going to come in really good and you're not not need to have late nights on that one.
把一集交给像克里斯这样的人你会感到兴奋，因为你知道这一集效果会非常好，而且你不需要为那一集熬夜。
At that point, we had never run a TV show before.
当时，我们从来没有运作过电视剧。
So at that point, I can't say it was anything more than this was a big one.
所以在那个时候，我不能说这不仅仅是因为这是一个大制作。
We're learning who Barney was.
我们在了解巴尼是谁。
It had to advance the story in the present while showing us who Barney was in the past.
它必须在展示巴尼过去的同​​时，推进现在的剧情。
High degree of difficulty, give it to Chris.
难度系数极高，交给克里斯。
I think that was part of the, so it was a compliment to Chris, for sure.
我想这是其中的一部分原因，所以这绝对是对克里斯的赞美。
But it also felt to me like in the arc of who was writing what, it always felt like the first episode was a you and Carter, the finales were you and Carter, and one or two in the middle were you and Carter, right?
但对我来说，在谁写什么的脉络中，感觉总是第一季是你们和卡特，大结局是你们和卡特，中间有一两集是你们和卡特，对吧？
Yeah, more than one or two, we usually did, because there were two of us, and we could, one guy could still be running the day to day of the show, and the other guy could peel off and write one, and it was sort of like, that's how we do it, one of us would sort of mostly do one episode and then the other, but both our names were on it.
对，不止一两集，我们通常都会参与，因为我们有两个人，我们可以一个人继续负责剧集的日常运作，另一个人抽身出来写一集，这有点像是我们这样做的，我们中的一个人通常会主要负责一集，然后是另一个人，但我们两个人的名字都会写在上面。
Yeah, it's really like a Lennon McCartney situation, right?
对，这真的很像列侬和麦卡特尼的情况，对吧？
Like McCartney wrote Blackbird, but it's a Lennon McCartney song.
就像麦卡特尼写了《Blackbird》，但它是一首列侬-麦卡特尼的歌。
Yeah, except like a much worse Lennon and McCartney.
对，除了像个糟糕得多的列侬和麦卡特尼。
Like them, but nowhere near as talented.
就像他们一样，但远没有那么有才华。
So that kind of gives you the scope.
所以这大致让你了解了规模。
And everyone's all, I come in with my octopus's garden.
每个人都在说，我带着我的《章鱼的花园》来了。
And it's great to have you here, Ringo.
很高兴你能来，林戈。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
Here comes the sun, motherfucker.
太阳出来了，他妈的。
Here comes the sun.
太阳出来了。
That's Chris Harris.
那是克里斯·哈里斯。
Come on.
拜托。
Don't.
别这样。
But by the way, I hope this is Garden's fucking great, too.
但顺便说一句，我希望《章鱼的花园》也他妈的很棒。
No one's losing out here.
这里没有人是输家。
We love you, Ringo.
我们爱你，林戈。
But no.
不过说真的。
But yeah, Carter and I, yeah, we would sort of mostly take one or the other, but it would always kind of go through the other guy first and say, hey, add some awesomeness, or sometimes help dig me out of a problem on this.
但卡特和我，是的，我们基本上会各自负责一集，但通常总是先让对方过目，然后说：“嘿，加点精彩元素，或者有时帮我摆脱这个困境。”
So we would each weigh in on each other's episodes.
所以我们都会对彼此的剧集提出意见。
But over time it became more like Carter ran a room, I ran a room and then we sort of tripped.
但随着时间的推移，它变得更像是卡特管理一个编剧室，我管理一个编剧室，然后我们有点分道扬镳了。
So it was like that.
所以它就像那样。
But Chris, we would have given Chris this episode with Great Glee knowing it was a really important big one.
不过克里斯，我们本来就会很高兴把这集交给克里斯，因为知道这真的是非常重要的一大集。
Okay.
好的。
So a lot of questions, Chris, from the fans, we were talking about the fact that fans, especially ones who came to it later or binging it, they get the whole series as a book that they just read all at once.
所以有很多关于粉丝的问题，克里斯，我们一直在讨论这样一个事实：粉丝们，尤其是那些后来才看或者一口气刷完的人，他们把整部剧当作一本书，一下子就读完了。
Whereas you're making it as a newspaper, right?
而你们制作它就像是在办一份报纸，对吧？
to sort of make you one every day and hope that if you see a fire truck in one episode and seven years later there's another fire truck where you're planning on there being two fire trucks you right they kind of see all of that.
每天为你炮制一份，希望如果他们在某一集里看到一辆消防车，而在七年后的另一集里又看到另一辆消防车，而你计划中本来就有两辆消防车，他们就会把这些全都串联起来。
So there's a couple of questions on that.
所以关于这一点有几个问题。
I just want to talk about in the large this notion of big how much you were looking at big picture planning ahead or that you were just treading water.
我只想从宏观上谈谈这种“宏大”的概念，即你们在多大程度上着眼于全局、提前规划，还是仅仅在随波逐流。
For example in drum roll please season one episode 13 Barney he picks up a bridesmaid saying he's going to be away for two years with the Peace Corps.
比如，请敲黑板，第一季第十三集里，巴尼搭讪了一个伴娘，说他要加入和平队离开两年。
Was that foreshadowing of this episode or did you just think about it as a callback or are you not noting it until I literally I'm saying it to you right now based on your thoughts.
那是对这一集的伏笔，还是你只是把它当作一个前后呼应的梗，或者直到我此刻基于你的想法直接说出来，你才注意到这一点？
Can I can I recover and say it was all planned?
我能、我能圆回来，说这都是计划好的吗？
I have no recollection of that, but we were there were there were pretty close together.
我完全不记得了，但它们当时离得确实挺近的。
So I wonder we owned it.
所以我很好奇，我们认领了。
I think we thought we do we thought that Barney had some like the ingredients for that lie were based on some part of who he used to be.
我想我们认为，我们觉得巴尼有一些——那个谎言的成分是基于他过去的一部分经历。
I think we I think we did own it or we liked that that sort of echoed that.
我想我们、我想我们确实认领了，或者我们喜欢那种前后呼应的感觉。
I think I think that was semi-intentionally.
我想、我想那是半有意为之的。
It's also funny to consider like if she quizzed him on the Peace Corps, he'd be able to ace it.
而且想象一下，如果她考他关于和平队的问题，他绝对能对答如流，这也挺搞笑的。
He would know how to answer those Questions, yeah.
他会知道怎么回答那些问题，是的。
Yeah, I think that was a tunnel.
对，我想那是顺理成章的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我还为你写了一首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，是播客“超精准解决”的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的烦恼：我30岁了，却害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有一个问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的“超精准解决”播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它，或者访问HyperFixedPod.com。
We talked about this a little bit on the main episode, but just to go over to the game, because a lot of people talked about the board games.
我们在正片里稍微讨论过这个，但为了转到游戏这个话题，因为很多人都在讨论桌游。
A lot of people talked about the board game and the least father, Terri O.D., So to, oh, by the way, I want to give to that previous question that was Gabborn, Gabborn 15.
很多人都在讨论桌游和莉丝的父亲，泰里·O·D，等等，哦，顺便说一句，我想回到刚才那个问题，那是加博恩，加博恩15提出的。
This is Terio D02.
这是泰里·O·D02。
Was this knowingly the beginning of Marshall's love of making board games throughout the series?
这算不算是马修在整部剧中热爱制作桌游的开端？
And if so, who or what was the inspiration of this character trait?
如果是的话，这个角色特质的灵感来源是谁或者是什么？
Where did this come from?
这到底是怎么来的？
Yeah.
对。
Well, I mean, we talked about it in the main episode of the main podcast episode.
嗯，我的意思是，我们在主剧集的播客里讨论过这个。
I think it was a lot of Chris.
我觉得克里斯占了很大比重。
There was a lot of Chris in there, Chris loves stuff like that, right?
里面有很多克里斯的影子，克里斯很喜欢这种东西，对吧？
I mean, that was you.
我的意思是，那个人就是你。
I don't know if I had the original notion that Marshall is great at games and makes up his own games.
我不知道最初是不是我的想法，即马修擅长游戏并且自己发明游戏。
I think that might have just been a room thing, but I definitely jumped on that in terms of like, oh, I can write this.
我觉得那可能只是编剧室里的一个点子，但我绝对抓住不放，心里想，哦，这个我能写。
You love that world's disentine in a very intricate, like.
你喜欢那种非常复杂的世界观……
I bet I can get it.
我打赌我能搞定。
It sounds tough, but I bet I can get inside the head of someone who likes games and puzzles.
听起来很难，但我敢说我能走进喜欢游戏和解谜的人的内心世界。
It's gonna be really difficult.
这将会非常困难。
Well, you really made that stretch, Chris.
好吧，你可真会往自己脸上贴金，克里斯。
I really was really brave, Leeve.
我当时可真是勇敢呢，莉夫。
Isn't it funny to consider, though, in the first season of something, if you think, okay, one of these characters is obsessive about board games, you could kind of make the case that any of them could be, or conversely, any of them hated board games.
不过，在一档节目的第一季里，如果你想：好吧，其中一个角色对桌游有执念，你其实可以说他们当中任何一个人都可以这样，反过来说，他们任何一个人讨厌桌游也说得通，这不觉得很搞笑吗？
Like, you were still assigning things to people.
就像，你当时还在给每个人分配人设呢。
Oh, totally, yeah, Robin's super competitive, so she's super into games, or really- Or Robin hates board games, she can't stand them.
哦，完全是，是的，罗宾超级好胜，所以她超级喜欢游戏，或者真的很——或者罗宾讨厌桌游，她简直对它们深恶痛绝。
She had an incident in high school with board games, scarred her, you know, Ted, you could very clearly see being in board games, you know?
她在高中时经历过一次关于桌游的事故，给她留下了心理阴影，你知道的，泰德，你也很容易看出他会喜欢桌游，对吧？
It does echo, it echoes with bass guy's ball a little bit.
这确实有点呼应，跟巴斯·盖伊的球有点呼应。
Like the idea of Erickson's invent weird games.
就像埃里克森一家发明奇奇怪怪的游戏这个概念。
It echoes with that, I don't remember if that was intentional, but it does a little bit.
它跟那个有呼应，我不记得这是不是故意的，但确实有点像。
That's a great point.
这真是个好观点。
But yeah, to Josh's point, like at the beginning of a season of a show, like that's both the exciting thing.
不过是的，正如乔希所说，在一档节目第一季的开头，既有令人兴奋的地方。
You can assign anything to anyone, but it's also the scary thing because you don't know, you don't like later on, oh, Marshall, you know, who wants to be a God parent?
你可以把任何特质分配给任何人，但这也是让人害怕的地方，因为你不知道，你不会像后来那样想：哦，马修，你知道的，谁想当教父？
We know that Marshall loves games, this makes sense.
我们知道马修热爱游戏，这说得通。
And so we have this information about these characters that we can extrapolate and build further stories from, but there's a lot of blank slate at the beginning of a show.
因此我们掌握了这些关于角色的信息，我们可以以此进行推断并构建更多故事，但在节目的开头，有很多空白页。
So it's...
所以它……
No, in the writer's room, is it just like a collective hive mind memory?
不对，在编剧室里，这就像是一个集体的蜂群思维记忆吗？
Are the writer's assistants like the gatekeepers of like, no, you can't do that because you have this?
编剧助理就像是守门人吗，会说“不，你不能那样做，因为你之前已经设定过这个了”？
Like, how does that work?
这究竟是怎么运作的？
Writer's assistants are very helpful in that regard.
在这方面，编剧助理非常有用。
We had really good ones on our show and they go, wait a second, no, you said this earlier.
我们的剧组里有非常优秀的助理，他们会说：“等一下，不对，你之前说过这个。”
I was so, what was great is anyone on staff could do that though.
最棒的是，剧组里的任何人都可以做到这一点。
You know, like hair and makeup could say that.
你知道，比如发型和化妆师都可以这么说。
Dave Baker and props could say that like, everyone cared for the intricacy of this universe we were creating the kind of world building component that I think we got those notes and those good catches.
负责道具的戴夫·贝克也可以这么说，每个人都在精心维护我们所创造的这个宇宙的错综复杂感，那种世界构建的成分，我想我们收到了那些笔记和精彩的抓包。
And sometimes those clever pitches, sometimes you go down to the set and either set deck or Dave or whatever, had added things in based on character traits from earlier episodes, seasons, years before, and you come and you go, You remembered this, you know, there's a lock in his monster thing, you're banging in a room and it's just like a really funny, subtle joke, you know, that's all that's props that's set dressing.
有时是那些聪明的点子，有时你走到片场，无论是布景装饰还是戴夫或其他人，都会根据前几集、前几季、多年前的角色特质添加一些东西，然后你走过来就会说：“你们居然还记得这个，你知道的，有个锁匠的东西，你在房间里敲敲打打，这就像是一个非常搞笑、微妙的笑话，你知道的，全靠道具和布景。”
That's like a lot of the time the writing had nothing to do with those touches.
很多时候，剧本跟这些点缀毫无关系。
And it was just how genius the larger creative team was on the show.
这只是因为这档节目背后的整个创意团队是多么的天才。
So the I have a good conversation started to end us in the next question.
所以，我有一个很好的对话开端来结束我们接下来的问题。
But the penultimate question here is definitely the one that had the most questions on Instagram.
但这里的倒数第二个问题绝对是Instagram上收到最多问题的一个。
And again, it goes to how much you know, um, I think it's like the George Lucas version of it that he knew a lot of this.
而且，这再次涉及到你了解多少，嗯，我觉得这有点像乔治·卢卡斯的版本，他知道很多这方面的事情。
He had this plan, but oh, did he really have that plan?
他有这个计划，但哦，他真的有这个计划吗？
And this and that.
诸如此类。
And then there's the, I know the Vince Gilligan version of writing where he really always talked about, we had no idea.
然后还有我所了解的文斯·吉里根式的写作，他总是说，我们根本不知道。
We just kept writing ourselves in the corners.
我们只是不断地把笔下的自己写进死胡同。
We need nothing that was going next.
我们对接下来要发生什么一无所知。
We'd write a cold open to something.
我们会写一段开场白。
We did know what we're we're going to pay off.
我们根本不知道要怎么收尾。
We only have some, you know, so the question is, okay, says star brace smoothie.jpeg and so many other people.
我们只知道一点，所以问题是，好吧，“star_brace_smoothie.jpeg”还有好多其他人都在问。
I've been waiting for this.
我一直在等这个。
Who gave Robin the mat is a Ted or Barney.
究竟是谁给罗宾垫的脚垫？是泰德还是巴尼？
This question has plagued me for years.
这个问题困扰我好几年了。
Oh, interesting.
哦，有意思。
That's an interesting thing.
这是一个有趣的问题。
I don't take it as a question.
我不认为这是一个问题。
It's interesting because I never, it never crossed my mind that it could have been someone other than Ted.
这很有趣，因为我从来没有、从来没想过除了泰德之外还会是别人。
Oh, we're talking about the Cherbotsky welcome method.
哦，我们是在说切尔巴茨基的欢迎地垫。
Yeah, I didn't think I thought it was Ted.
对，我没多想，我以为那就是泰德。
I thought I forgot something 100% Ted, 100% Ted.
我想我忘了点什么，100%是泰德，100%是泰德。
This was Ted making a nice gesture that actually plants an interesting seed of what's going to happen with Ted and Victoria moving forward.
这是泰德在表达善意，这实际上为一个有趣的伏笔埋下了种子，关于泰德和维多利亚接下来会发生什么。
I think I really liked that moment, but it was for sure, Ted.
我想我真的很喜欢那个时刻，但那绝对是泰德。
But I also thought that it could have been Robin until it was the reveal of Victoria that gave Ted the plastic vomit.
但我当时也想过，在维多利亚露面并给泰德送上塑料呕吐物之前，那也有可能是罗宾。
You're right.
你说得对。
Right.
没错。
And that could have been her, but it's also a nice, you know, day taunts, is that the word?
那也有可能是她，但这同样也是一个很好的，嗯，尾声（Dénouement），是这个词吗？
Like it's a piece of their weirdness.
就像是他们之间那种古怪性格的一个碎片。
Yeah, the last we saw was that awkwardness.
对，我们最后看到的正是那种尴尬。
And then it's like, okay, where it seems, it seems like they're getting passed.
然后就好像是，好吧，看起来，看起来他们正在释怀。
I really liked how awkward that moment was, by the way, where and Barney's like, you were right, Ted, you really shouldn't have told that story.
顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢那种尴尬的气氛，就是巴尼说，你说得对，泰德，你真不该讲那个故事。
That was, that was a good like literally just swimming in that awkwardness and it doesn't really get resolved except for that, that moment in the montage.
But that moment of resolution is important.
we had to reconnect head in Victoria to deepen them in the next couple of episodes.
And that little moment between them is really important.
It's a great song to do that in my morning jacket song off record.
Great, great indie rock, needle drop.
And that is important because we need to care about and invest in Victoria because what's to come between them is going to be the main narrative in the next couple of episodes.
I really like that little moment between them.
And I remembered one little breaking the story thing that I could throw in really fast, which was, at one point in the room, when Carter and Craig were not away, there was this extra twist that was added where it was like, oh, Barney actually, this actually was an audition tape, and Barney faked being part of the part, you know, this whole story just to get Ted to tell the re-return.
And it was so smart to like, no, of course not.
That's too much.
It breaks the story.
It's this naked, it's tail, yeah.
Yeah, and it's like, it's too much.
And I feel like that was a learning experience for me, which is like, no, let's live in this.
This is the reel of how Barney was.
And I don't know, I just remember thinking, oh, wow, that was such the right call.
I completely forgot about that.
Yeah, it was like an extra twist.
And we're like, oh, no, now it's just all madness.
It's a hat on a hat.
It must be a hat on a hat.
When you guys think it must be fun to watch these episodes because in your mind, you might actually think, No, that did happen because it happened in the writer's room and you forget, you forget where it landed.
Chris, I'm just now remembering that you and I had a bit that lasted almost all nine seasons.
Wasn't the bit that I thought you were lying about having gone to Stanford?
Yes, you had a, in fact, I had, hold on, I had, I, I, I, I wondered if you were going to bring that up.
So I said, when will Josh use the phrase back when I was at Stanford?
which was, which was, which is like, but I guess 1326 in on the original.
Oh my god, that was a bit, that was a bit, it was a bit, that I said that you were always saying, starting to sit back when I was at Stanford.
And then it evolved into, I don't think you actually went to Stanford.
Yeah, that became, yeah, come on, what you, what, you don't, it was something like, you don't need to say this to me, I'm not, you know, try to impress me.
And I remember you kept going like, no, I really didn't go there.
I did, I went there.
Yeah, I know, because you say back when I was at Stanford all the time.
But the idea that Chris had the guest pre-written on, like, sort of like a newly-wet game style card.
It's like Johnny Carson's Envelope.
It's the absolute great con act.
Like, with the fact that Chris just did that, Chris was just Marshall in this episode.
Yeah.
Chris was just the game master.
He held up.
He had a guest of the time.
That was full.
That was Marshall.
And it didn't even occur to me until right now we've been talking for a long time.
I know, I'm flattered.
I'm flattered, it didn't come up earlier.
There's a deeper thing at play, which is the writers and the actors got to know each other and were friends and really like symbiotic, it was a symbiotic relationship, you know?
Absolutely, yeah.
And then stories went back and forth and things that actors, that stories came out of things that happened on stage.
It was awesome.
And just to say, not to sound too back in my day or too like pro-union guy, this is what the writer's guild was striking for, in part, right?
The idea that writers should be on shoots, writers shouldn't pre-write things and then disappear and then it's shot and they're separate.
The actors and the writers getting to know each other actually impacts the final part.
And when Chris was on his day for his own episodes, he would come up with all lines that were hilarious and made it into the episodes.
I remember I would accuse you, I would say, you would say, back when I was at Stanford, Do you think Ted has to cross on that line, or should he cross on that line?
I was like, Chris, you didn't need to say back when I was in Stanford.
I really don't think I said that.
I can't believe we're having this argument again.
Yeah.
Well, Chris, we're delighted we have the door is open.
Please come back and talk about how I made it by the way again.
When I think about how I made your mother, your face is on the Mount Rushmore.
So thanks for being here.
Despite the snamford wire.
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
How we major mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
Artwork by John Morrow.
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
It really does help the show.
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
Want some merch?
Click on the store link, or go to howyougetyourmerch.com.
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Mews Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
People will, in fact, dance.